happy holidays everyone this week it's
going to be the best of for all of 2022
listeners and editors choices as to the
greatest exchanges from a lot of
incredible conversations have a
wonderful holiday with you and yours and
we will see you in the new year 2022
best of coming up next
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it is my pleasure and privilege to
Welcome to the podcast one of the
greatest investors of all time that's no
exaggeration to say uh and number one
New York Times best-selling author
including author of The extraordinary
new book principles for dealing with a
changing World Order why Nations succeed
and fail Ray dalio the head of
Bridgewater the biggest hedge fund in
the world joins us thank you so much for
being here Ray thank you for the
opportunity to talk with you and your
audience you had a sentence in your book
that I thought was maybe the strong
ascendants I'd ever seen from a business
leader that I was not aware of until I
read your book in full which was you
said that you think that the odds of
America slipping into a civil war type
scenario over the next 10 years is
around 30 and you characterize that as
like not that high a risk I feel like
that should be A1 headline news
everywhere and by the way way I'm with
you like I I agree with you here's what
I think
is happening and and probably will
happen the populism of the left and the
right uh are individuals who will are
Fighters for those constituencies and
um there are very different values very
different approaches what that means is
that there's little compromise and
there's much greater extremism very much
like happened in Europe four major
democracies in the 1930 to 45 period had
this type of internal conflict that
ended up their parliaments their uh
legislatures choosing to have
autocracies that they went to
autocracies on Germany Italy Japan and
Spain and if you study history you see
it was the same in the fresh Revolution
the Russian Revolution the Cuban
Revolution the Chinese Revolution which
are all sort of Civil Wars you lose the
middle and you because you have to say
Andrew you got to get on one side or
another and fight when the causes that
people are behind are more important to
them than the system the system is in
Jeopardy and so you see just even people
moving from place to place in terms of
where they think it's more uh
sympathetic to their way of being and
what they're like you know New York
Chicago San Francisco California moves
to Texas and so on and you're seeing um
then
um not a not as much respect for the
Constitution and the legal system
because you have a win at all cost so
for example if you have the dispute
between
um let's say Disney and the Florida
governor in the past there would have
been almost mutual respect for different
points of view but what you now get back
is you get back to a power conflict well
you know what would the odds put I'll
ask you what you think the odds are that
for example temple in the next
presidential election that neither side
accepts losing you know I'd say almost
too close to call
um and what is the possibility that
states do not follow the directions of
the Supreme Court decisions because the
Supreme Court decisions can be viewed by
one side as a political decision made by
the other Supreme Court and how do we
get around that or whatever just like
Sanctuary cities in other words I will
not follow that rule and that and so now
you start to have a breakdown of the
system and you have power politics
determining things so I think that that
kind of uh Civil War is relatively
likely I I don't disagree with you at
all Ray anyone who listens to me knows
that I've been trying to sound an alarm
on this so one of the things you say in
your book is that you think One Way Out
of This Is Us strong Peacemaker and we
pray for them but you say that that's
not something that uh generally happens
uh that generally the other thing
happens
um what what I'm trying to do have you
seen any of uh Catherine Galler
Michael's or Michael Porter's work on
political incentives because well one of
the things that's driving our
polarization is that we have these party
primaries that disproportionately
empower the most extreme 10 of partisan
voters so one thing we're trying to do
is change the mechanics of our election
so that it's not just the most extreme
uh hyper partisans choosing our leaders
and then re-electing them right now you
have 20 of Americans happy with Congress
which is very very low but the
re-election rate for individual members
is 94 which is astronomically high but
your book talks about the increase in
polarization as a precursor to some of
these very negative things happening and
there are other societies that have
democracies that have more than two
parties that's actually the norm in most
of the world and so what we're trying to
do it Forward is change the mechanics so
that you can have more points of view
emerge and then start a positive
unifying third-party force that
represents the reasonable middle that
can draw energy and resources and also
put pressure on both of the parties to
compromise I I don't know if this is
something that you've dug into and
explored either in terms of the
mechanics of why it seems like we're
getting uh more extreme polarized
leadership or if there have been other
countries that have reformed their way
out so I I think we're completely in
agreement much and just going back to
the mechanics I I think it has to do
with fear I hope
that we can have understand what the
context what what it means to have the
type of Civil War the what is the
probability and what does that mean
um like of a principle if you worry you
don't have to worry and if you don't
worry you need to worry that's a pretty
good rule of life if you worry
you'll take care of the thing you're
worrying about and you can worry less
and and if you don't then probably it'll
kill you the extremism
which um has problems in terms of
destroying a system is a terrible path
anybody who's gone through this and I I
mean it domestically as well as
internationally but the number one thing
is that the population has got to want
that and we have and in our two-party
system we have a problem because
um let's say there's about 30 percent of
the population I I would Define as being
uh rather uh extreme right and maybe
something like 15 of the population
being extreme left but as a percentage
of their uh uh own parties they're
relatively high and they're Gathering
more as their as the fight approaches
and so they become then dominant and you
have that particular result but the
power of the middle
if you can and and the power of of of
OZO compromise if you can bring that
about uh isn't as enormous because still
the majority of people are not in those
two we're we're talking about 45 of the
population maybe is is fairly extreme
and opposite ends
um but the majority still aren't there
and if the majority had they have to be
smart enough to know how to increase the
size of the pie and divide the pie well
to produce equal opportunity and unequal
and some element of sharing it to get
the balance right you wrote a number of
pieces in 2018 and 2019 about how we
need to try and reform the economy or
reform capitalism capitalism so that it
works for more people and one of the
stats that you cited was a stat that I
cited to on the trail which was that the
odds of American children doing better
than their parents uh are down to let's
say 50 50 and dropping which is one of
the things that's driving people to
anger frustration I mean it's very
fundamental you're a parent I'm a parent
if you felt like your kids are going to
do worse than you then you start looking
around being like okay what the heck is
is going wrong yes I wrote a study which
was why and how capitalism needs to be
reformed which was a very controversial
study but but it's an obvious fact that
if it's not benefiting the majority of
the people okay then just by its metrics
of success it's not a it's not going to
be successful and there are and reforms
doesn't mean gone away with it means
changing certain things that means it
works better keeping capitalism and so
on capitalists tend to be people who um
have new ideas and if you give them
capital and they can invent really good
things and improve it you know it's a
wonderful system it's been proven by
everybody it's been adopted by the
Chinese thing Xiaoping to make a better
system but it has to work in a way where
it produces the outcomes that you want
the middle the problem is capitalists
are better able of increasing the pie
but they don't know how to divide the
pie well they don't have to share it
well and socialists don't know how to
make it as good a pie but they divide it
well so I think you need the bipartisan
like if I was President of the United
States which by the way I will never be
I'm not writing but I would want to have
a bipartisan cabinet okay I'd put a
bipartisan cabinet and I would have the
equivalent to a Manhattan Project to
think about what reforms need to be made
to achieve that uh in other words of the
left of the right smart capable
mechanical at least Savvy individuals
who know about engineering and there
will have to be structural changes for
example let's say education
on the Constitution uh makes
um education a state issue which then is
in Most states become the local tax
District issue I know this well because
my wife
um and I to some except for her really
works in the worst school districts in
Connecticut I'll give you a stock
shocking statistic in Connecticut which
is one of the richest states in the
country 22 percent of the high school
students are either disengaged or
disconnected disengaged means that their
absentee rate is greater than 25 percent
they're failing classes oh my gosh and
disconnected means that they don't know
where they are because they dropped out
of school 22 percent of the high school
students are failing high school now
there's a cycle there they're in a poor
District they're not they don't have
parents to adequately take care of them
and so on the state of Connecticut spend
600 billion dollars a million dollars a
year on
um incarcerations
because there's that so the notion you
know like there's no better investment
than quality education but these types
of changes some have to be reformed
maybe it requires some Constitutional
Amendments but it certainly means
working together because the country or
the world as a whole has more resources
than it ever had it has more
intelligence than it ever had but it has
a choice is it going to go to war
or is it and which will make things
worse than ever or is it going to try to
find a way together to make that better
whole that's the choice I think we face
foreign
y'all I want to tell you about Helix
sleep because they make awesome
mattresses I love these things I've got
two I've got one for guests and one I
sleep on every night and they're this
fantastic mattress brand that provides
tailored mattresses based on your unique
sleep preferences so how do you know it
works for you you take the Helix sleep
quiz online and find your perfect
mattress in under two minutes so you
tell them whether you sleep hot or sleep
cold or sleep on your side and it gives
you a mattress that is perfectly
tailored for how you sleep and they've
got over 14 different kinds they've got
luxury models they've got big and tall
sleepers they've even got mattresses for
kids it's pretty awesome and the best
part of this
they actually have a deal for our
listeners that to me is pretty awesome
so
right now Helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners so get it for
the holidays they'll deliver it to you
if you don't like it get 100 night risk
free try it out situation so up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners so go to
helixsleep.com Yang with Helix better
sleep starts now
[Music]
philosopher rock star uh one of in my
Minds one of the most uh interesting
modern day intellectuals of our era
Coleman Hughes welcome Coleman it's
honored to be here so uh tell us about
the conversations you have that you
think that people are seeking I mean I
think there is an appetite for uh reason
and rationality uh for even temperedness
uh modern day
um philosophy if you will I can't like
I'm thinking about the philosophers I
know in
2022 and you know you could count them
uh in my mind on one hand and you're one
of them
um so what do you think uh
what are the big themes that that you
explore that are are appealing to people
yeah so I think that
the the basic theme I explored that was
the source of me getting a following on
Colette the my my podcast ballooning in
success during 2020 was that I really
think your race and your skin color
should not matter
in 99 of cases I think it doesn't matter
it's it's superficial
and what matters is our common Humanity
so the response to for a lot of people I
think which you've probably heard a
million times is well I certainly would
want it to be that way uh but is it that
way question mark and then people would
be like no so we have to do X Y right
so that that's an illogical argument
it's um
if you reply to race doesn't matter is
well the racists disagree
you're kind of proving my point
which is the people who make race matter
the people to whom race is important are
wrong
so we shouldn't fight them by agreeing
with their basic premise we should fight
them by rejecting their premise
and
too many people have decided the right
way to fight racism
is essentially to agree about the
underlying racial racial essentialism
Blackness and whiteness are really real
things they're really very important
they're core parts of my identity you
can't really understand me unless you
understand my
how the color of my skin is an intrinsic
feature of who I am a deep feature of
who I am that separates and divides us
such that you can't really there's some
incommunicable barrier between us
and we should organize our politics
around these
variables
um people have decided that that's the
only way or the best way to respond
to white supremacy and and racism and
the alt-right and so forth
and I I reject that I reject that
approach I I believe that
you know what is
I guess what used to be
called colorblindness
is really the the only philosophically
sound approach to have towards race and
I and I don't mean pretending not to see
race right I'm clearly Asian yes you're
clearly Asian I'm clearly not
is it the comedian Dove Davidoff has
this joke
where he's like uh I met this woman the
other day
who said she doesn't see race and I
thought good luck describing your
attacker that's like we're off just tell
tell the police to look for a man with a
frown
it was like the point is obviously
everyone sees race right
so that Pat phrase I don't see race is
false and misleading
but what people the the charitable
interpretation of that is I strive to be
a person that does not let race
influence my considered decisions and
that's the world that I want to create I
want to create a world where people
think about race less and less and less
and and the people who do obsess about
race are more and more ostracized from
the mainstream corridors of power well
this is a very uh interesting counter to
racism
um the tagline for my presidential
campaign was Humanity first so you can
imagine uh you know like this is the
world that I want the world where where
folks
uh don't use race as a
uh like a factor in you know the way
they treat people the way they respond
to
um to situations
so you've heard all the counter
arguments I'm sharing like I don't want
to be the person who like you know
belabors them no yeah I mean I'm
currently writing a book where I examine
every counter argument
that's that's out there it's uh so uh my
perspective on this is a a little
different than yours though again I
think we're aligned um so I grew up in a
majority white suburb
um in Upstate New York uh probably not
as diverse as Montclair it's one of the
only Asian kids uh and so like I got
picked on for being different uh pretty
much anyone who wasn't a white kid got
picked on for for being different and I
think that the culture has shifted in
ways where I like look at my boys I'm a
dad now I've got two little Asian boys
nine and six and I look at them I'm like
huh like are they going to experience
the same sort of thing
um and right now it doesn't seem like it
you know at least maybe not in the same
way certainly that my brother and I did
um uh and so my feeling on this is that
like that tribalism exists it's sort of
baked into human nature yeah
um and our goal should be to your point
one except that a certain level of
tribalism exists don't pretend that you
know you look at someone and be like oh
like you know I don't see that you're
like a different race
um and then you try and counter the
corrosive uh evil effects of that
tribalism in different ways and I agree
with you that the appeal to universalism
is a better working appeal than you know
reinforcing tribalism in different
respects um so I think everything I said
like doesn't disagree with you
yeah I mean no some level of tribalism
is inevitable and not only that there
are I would even concede that there are
certain times where tribalism is a a
good thing or it's it's the really the
only way to get people to go so far
above and beyond to help their fellow
man
so like realistically
there there have been times where you
know Jews were fleeing persecution and
one part of the world and they could
find Refuge with Jews that were total
strangers to them in a different part of
the world that would take them into
their homes right and
that's a kind of altruism that is tough
to get people to do absent tribalism
actually it's like they they accepted
Jews from a totally different part of
the world just because they were part of
the tribe and that so so I would even
carve out some some unique instances
where tribalism is the only plausible
way of getting people to just be super
altruistic and to to
people whom would other who would
otherwise be total strangers
but in most cases tribalism divides far
more than it brings people together and
it creates all of these inevitable
resentments when you put race into
policy right like when when Biden puts
into his uh restaurant relief covid
policy that
he's going to put to the front of the
line people restaurants that are owned
by people of color
regardless of the need the individual
needs of of sort of the struggling
restaurants that creates an
understandable resentment in a white
restaurant owner who's struggling who
knows all the specifics of situation how
hard he or she is working may even
employ mostly people of color you know
like I know examples like this and it's
like
I'm being put at the back of this line
on something that is really it's
well-meaning but it's it's harming me
for some for a reason that I can't
control
at the end of the day I don't think you
can ever ask people
to
to pay for arbitrary characteristics
that they were born into it will always
create resentment no matter how you
justify it so we have to get to some
equilibrium where we can seriously focus
on you know intergenerational poverty
neighborhoods that are stuck in
intergenerational poverty with high
crime rates and invest heavily
in that as as an independent problem but
really create and Foster a a colorblind
General
legal and political foundation so uh
when I think about racism I think about
the fact that uh
Economic Opportunity and educational
opportunity are vastly uneven I think
the average black household has
something like 10 percent the net worth
of The Average White household and and
so I I think of it more in terms of uh
the
economic disparities and the realities
then I do like the like the way
individuals treat each other and I was
with a black person uh when I was
running for president and that person
was like look I don't care if like
everyone loves me I just want my schools
to be better or whatever it is right I
mean that was that was really the
attitude of I mean the attitude of all
the great civil rights leaders we look
back on and admire like Dr King and
Byron Rustin and they all I mean as
compelling as as Martin Luther King was
in terms of actually getting
white Americans that were on the fence
to support the civil rights movement and
to want to bring black people into the
into the fully into the American fold
they were not at the end of the day
focused on getting all white people to
like like them right like they they
understood they had a very hard-headed
approach
that you don't have to like me
but you do have to do my [ __ ] yeah you
do have to let me
be free right you have to let like
participate I want you to change this
and change that like you know how you
feel about me right afterwards right is
less relevant yes so I mean the the
truth is there's always going to be
bigots in the world
always
and there's and you know over time I
think the amount of bigots has actually
reduced somewhat as ideas have changed
as people have met people from different
races and ethnic groups meet each other
and mingle and
but it's never going to go away ever
it's like and and people have a totally
implicitly they have an unrealistic
attitude to this which is like for
instance no one expects the murder rate
to ever be zero even in like these
Western European countries that we look
to that have far less violence than we
do men are more homogeneous yeah and I'm
more homogeneous than we are I have very
different circumstances but
even there
no one expects to have a murder rate of
literal zero right like there's always
going to be
a guy that finds out his wife has been
cheating and like murders the other guy
and you can't fully prevent it nor do we
have that benchmark
like a literal zero Benchmark for
success and bigotry is the same way you
can never you can't fully purify
human the human mind
very happy to Welcome to the podcast
Monica Guzman the author of I never
thought of it that way how to have
fearlessly curious conversations and
dangerously divided times and the chief
Storyteller for one of my favorite
organizations in all the world braver
Angels welcome Monica how are you hey
hey I am doing great it's good to be
here so yeah how did you become so
passionate about trying to have curious
conversation I mean you're naturally
curious person that seems to be a
driving theme of your career
um uh but the your book what I love
about it is that it actually is
practical
um it's born of the you know the
experience you've had getting hundreds
maybe thousands of people to open up
yeah that was definitely a goal from the
beginning uh I had read a lot about why
we're here how we got here it's a really
interesting problem and we haven't
solved it the first part of my book is
called SOS it's the call for help
sorting othering siloing those are the
three forces that brought us here yeah I
mean it's a it's a real you know but the
other four-fifths of the book uh walk
people through this path where first we
understand curiosity and how it works in
our brains when we when we pay attention
to the gap between what we know and what
we don't know it's this incredible
craving that can get us to do so much
and so you can actually turn it on you
don't have to wait for it to come up you
can turn it on and channel it and Target
right the things you don't understand
and then we learn the power of
conversation especially a one-to-one
conversation it's people are you know
scared of them in some ways because they
are so unpredictable and so powerful
that it doesn't even matter almost who
you are outside the conversation in that
conversation you can have this
extraordinary ability to cut through any
divide if you if you know how to ask
perceptive and Powerful questions if you
know how to stay respectful and build
traction with each other and then you
know the book goes on through a series
of solutions or you know things to try
that are based um around a couple of
core ideas and I'll mention one of them
now which is that knowing where people
are coming from is one of the best ways
to understand where they are so asking
questions about people's experiences
that led to their views and asking
questions about the concerns people have
around their issues are great ways to
not be so judgmental so that you can be
curious when you're curious you actually
cannot be judgmental these are two
different modes
um so pushing us away from judgment back
into curiosity back into curiosity back
into curiosity does amazing things for
our relationships people you know I've
learned as a journalist people love to
talk about themselves oh yeah if it's in
a generous context they want to tell
their story who doesn't want to be heard
yeah most of us love to hear ourselves
talk because we're we're very wise we
have a lot I think we think we are but
you know what but no the serious point
is you know we live in a society that
that sort of still thinks well you know
you're only as wise as your education
you're only as wise as your intelligence
you know you're only as wise as these
things and we don't we don't think about
wisdom all that much we all have life we
all are experts in life and we have
walked our own paths through it and
everybody's path is interesting no
matter what you conclude if you believe
a bunch of baloney your path still
contains a lot of Truth
and so it's those things that we need to
mind and and look behind you know all
those places that we feel were stuck
look behind that to the person's path to
their story and you'll you'll discover
pretty interesting stuff that'll help
you relate and connect not agree that's
not that's not the point but relate and
connect so that we can
do stuff together
yeah Live Together live together so we
we can't let this conversation end
without talking about family a bit do
you have a family of your own now yes
two kids nine and seven wow me too uh
same ages nine and six two boys so your
parents must now be very happy that uh
their their grandparents and all that
jazz um so they have no choice but uh oh
they love it they love it but you you
talked about how you've had political
disagreements uh with them for for a
long time uh go ahead and give guidance
to folks who might have a similar
situation uh in their family where they
feel like there's this uh political
divide yeah and this is where you know
my my inbox has become like a a
confession Booth you know a place where
a lot of people are telling me about
these stories with family where there's
such strong relationships one story I
can think of that I shared with braver
angels is a woman named Courtney who's
very purple herself doesn't consider
herself Reddit blue but cares deeply
about some political issues and loves
her father dearly and and there was a
moment where they fought so hard about
politics that her father said that's it
we just can't talk about politics
anymore no no and so I mean that seemed
like okay for maybe a bit but what
Courtney realized and I think a lot of
people are realized is that when when
you care deeply about certain issues and
and you know you're very concerned about
them
um then it feels like when you can't
talk about politics
you can't even be yourself and the
people you love can't know you or see
you and and that's the thing that we
can't
that's no way to live in a way right
like if we have these meaningful
relationships what gives them meaning is
that we can be our full selves around
each other so that's the conundrum for a
lot of people the solution is well we
just don't talk about politics and maybe
that's fine you know if it's just
Thanksgiving dinners and here and there
and you keep that bridge open that's
fine but in times like this when it's
just so much more heat and stress you
want to be able to do something about it
so among the the most powerful I think
things that you can try is we tend to
want to engage with each other on the
level of logic and syllogism and reason
right why do you believe what you
believe how could you possibly believe
what you believe you know but even if
you take the the disrespectful tone out
and you leave why do you believe what
you believe even then we think of why as
such a powerfully curious question but
in times of division and suspicion why
puts people on the defensive it makes
them Reach for uh what's the talking
point what's the thing that oh gosh I
better show up well to this relative of
mine or they're going to think less of
me or here we go I'm being put to the
test it's like you're on trial we're
putting each other on trial when we ask
why and everyone has to think of their
reason and and they won't think of
candid reasons usually you know they'll
just go for what feels safe because so
many people are not even comfortable
sharing their political beliefs so
instead ask questions around how
how did you come to believe what you
believe
you know what comes up for you like so
Dad I know that you and I disagree
hugely about immigration and I'm I'm
really curious like what what kind of
things have happened you know in your
life that that make you make you think
that your position on this is is really
important and ask it that way and and
what happens is that the questions
naturally carry a lot less judgment and
what you're doing is you're collecting
sort of knowledge about that person's
path that person's experience how did
you come to this mistake in an opinion
I'm kidding right well that's the thing
you got to peel off the disrespect keep
them curious people think that every
question is curious like journalists
know better right some questions are
just accusations disguised as questions
they're just gotcha they're meant to
disqualify people
I I know that you have
you know and sometimes it's in the
public good because it's a powerful
person blah blah blah we know that but
with each other on a one-to-one
relationship level if we're trying to
build trust
you know if we're trying to build trust
then we have to accept we have to accept
each other first which is the radical a
thing and then understand each other and
then judge I mean what we're doing is
we're judging recklessly because we
don't even see we're not even seeing
each other clearly
so when we judge what are we judging
we're judging projections we're judging
ghosts
you know that's no way to build a
society so we have to fix that we have
to get each other's stories and have
them and invite people to take us on a
tour through their path and the concerns
and the experiences that make it up uh
instead of put them on trial wow you
could really do a lot of good Monica
can I can I tell you there's there's a
woman who left a review of my book on
Amazon
it like brought me to tears but she said
that she had not talked to her 85 year
old mother who had voted for Trump for
years and that she read the book and she
thought the tips were pretty good and so
she put them to work and she says you
know she started listening to her mom
and asking different kinds of questions
and now she says their relationship is
really good and I I mean that made it
all worth it you know yeah that would
make everything worth it that made it
all worth it I will share with you that
uh I got dozens of times over my
campaign
um like thank you you helped bring our
family together because you know like
you helped uh us feel like we could like
agree on something yeah and like that
was like an incredible blessing to hear
I was like wow yeah you know another
thing that someone said to me too is
like they had a um Trump supporting mom
um and they themselves were were blue
and then their mom said to them that
like Yang is the only demo Democrat I
would support because he doesn't feel
like he's judging us at all and I was
like holy cow like this is probably very
important lesson there yeah and I mean
she's right like I have zero judgment on
um people based upon their political
beliefs I actually thinking I understand
what's driving a lot of what what's
happening in in this country yeah you
made such an important contribution and
you're doing it every day
um I I but I'm going to wrap on this
thought that's been stuck in my head a
little bit I'm going to run it by you
and see see what you think so it feels
like the Republican Party under Trump
has become this version of sort of angry
toxic masculinity like the crazy uncle
or or Grandpa and then the Democratic
party has become this
um somewhat like uh you know identity
Laden uh moralism that like most people
don't feel is genuine and and so when
you talk about like the fan the country
needing family of therapy like this is
an idea that's stuck with me yeah I mean
I think I think both parties are in this
place of confusion and and panic and a
little bit of Madness because we all are
uh and that that's what happens I think
when everything's a fun house mirror and
we're not sure what to do about it so
yeah the parties are just an extension
the same way that media is an extension
and politics politicians right their
behavior in the conventions all an
extension of of what we're feeling on
the ground and what's going on on the
ground every time I talk with my parents
so they're they're conservative they
voted for Trump twice
um and I'm liberal but as I say in the
book I I've gotten to the point where if
I know that if I were them
I would have voted for Trump too
wow that's a very very big and knowing
that yeah like it is it's a tough thing
to admit and it took a bit to be able to
admit it in the book but getting to the
place where I could admit that it was it
was sort of well here they are and here
I am now what
it's it's not I need to defeat you I
need to change you yes a different
question it's we need to build the
society together that somehow balances
uh the different stacks of values that
we have people think people look across
the divide and say they don't share my
values but but actually they do they
just stack them in a different order for
different issues you know when we
develop different communities different
communities develop different languages
and over time if they don't interact
that well it's a Tower of Babel you know
and that's what's happening too so
that's only adding to the panic and the
frustration and the madness so we need
some of these uh you know it counter
things but again I've I've talked to
members of Congress you know one-on-one
on background people want to fix this
and and I for one am really encouraged
by the work a lot of politicians are
doing um including yourself just anyone
who's really tackling this Beast instead
of just accepting the game as it is we
need that
foreign
senior fellow at the Brookings
institution the author of The Incredible
and important new book of boys and men
why the modern male is struggling why it
matters and what to do about it Richard
Reeves welcome Richard
thank you for having me on Andrew
looking forward to this
yeah me too uh congratulations for
taking on this important topic so
Brookings just a level set for everyone
Brookings is generally considered the
number one think tank in all the land
and you are a wonk uh an economist like
what was your work in prior to examining
uh what's happening with boys and men
yeah I think I have to correct you
already Andrew I think it's number one
in the world
sorry about that right just like the
Brookings fun people are going to kill
me if I don't correct you it's like the
global number one thing thing
um and interesting when I when I moved
to the US from from the UK in 2012 I'd
served in the government over there my
wife said to me what is where would you
most like to win like where's the dream
job for you and I said scholar of the
Brookings Institution
and I'm really fortunate that that is
exactly where I landed uh and that's
because the Brookings institution is is
the non-partisan it's authoritative our
values are quality Independence and
impact which means that we can do our
work without looking over one shoulder
or the other worrying about Which senate
is going to call you or just do the best
you can and my work previously is
focused mostly on on economic inequality
and lack of upward Mobility what are the
barriers to people being upwardly mobile
and that was true in the UK and now in
the US and that gets into issues of
class differences in the U.S obviously
race differences in the US but that then
led me to this new Focus because I on
boys and men because as I was doing that
work I just kept stumbling across these
inequalities that actually were
troubling and which didn't go the way
you would expect to go when you talk
about gender equality you presume you're
always talking about women and girls
sometimes you still are but increasingly
we now have to look at the problems
facing boys and men and so that that my
work on inequality and family and class
led me to the new focus on boys and men
so you open the book
um with the fact that some people try to
warn you off this topic
but then you end the book saying that
everyone actually is interested in the
topic
which made it feel like there's this
undercurrent
um but people hadn't publicly uh
spoken about it and kind of were afraid
to
yeah I I one of the reasons I ended up
attacking the subject was because so
many of the people that I was talking to
this was the issue right the school
Gates over the dinner table over at
lunch break uh people were talking about
their sons they were talking about their
brothers their uncle's and just how they
were struggling either in school or in
the labor market but particularly if
they were on the on the center left that
wasn't something they took out into
public that was something that would
remain private so they felt like there
was this gap between a lot of the
private anxiety people are feeling
including among many liberals and the
public discourse around this issue and
so it was almost like it was like it was
the inequality that dare not speak its
name at least from the center left and
and so it was into that space that I
really felt I was trying to some extent
bridge the gap between the schoolgate
conversations and the political
conversations where there's really been
a deafening silence especially on the
center left and then a weaponization on
the right which I'm sure we'll get into
yeah so let's get this out of the way
really quick um I I wrote a book the war
on normal people that delved into some
of the issues that are facing men
particularly as their most common
livelihoods have been uh automated or
globalized away and it's not a zero-sum
game where you can be concerned about
boys and men and uh still be very much
for uh elevating women in area is that
they've been discriminated against in or
marginalized or generally advocating for
gender equality the argument you make is
that look gender equality is gender
equality in the sense that if there are
Realms that one gender is is really
really falling behind and for example
Boys in school that also is gender
equality and it's a very legitimate
thing for us to be concerned about and
try to address
yeah that's right and and you know
credit to you Andrew and also you were
kind enough to endorse this book but
your Washington Post piece uh I think
was an important intervention uh and
you've obviously had Warren Farrell on
on here before and talked to him and so
I think you are one of the one of the
few public figures who have been willing
to engage in this issue in good in good
faith and and what I would say is a
positive way which does avoid exactly
that Zero Sum framing you've just
described which is this if we've
presented with this Choice like whose
side do you want effectively right and
they're even raising the fat and there
are some areas where boys and men are
struggling means that you have to stop
paying attention to the areas where
women and girls are struggling is just
it's a nonsensical false Choice classic
the classic example of culture War uh
paralysis and actually you know my wife
for example is trying to raise money
right now
um for a startup and you you all know
some of these stories and Drew but you
know so I know on a very personal basis
and the only two percent of venture
capital money goes to female Founders
right I'm reminded of that on at least a
daily basis and it's true and it's a
problem and then there are other areas
we could talk about where there remain
no problems and barriers facing women
and girls it doesn't mean we have to
then ignore the problems facing boys and
then it's a it's a false choice and it
turns out it turns out people can think
two thoughts at once a politicians
struggle to do that but more Ordinary
People are perfectly capable of doing
that yeah it's a symptom of our
polarized environment where it's like
choose a side and then you know you you
wind up in this inflamed environment uh
when I was running for president I
became very acutely aware of the issues
facing boys and men and one story that
did come across my my desk from Warren
Farrell was that there was another
democratic presidential candidate who
said I can't talk about this because I'm
in a Democratic primary
[Laughter]
in my mind uh perverse
um and messed up so let's dig into the
problems that you identify so broadly
speaking it's school and its work and
you have some prescriptions for each so
let's start with school boys are
struggling at school uh from the get-go
essentially K-12 uh the stats are
staggering I will confess that I am a
dad of two boys mine are much younger
than yours it sounds like yours are in
their early 20s yeah mine are nine and
seven
um but the the data around boys
struggling in school and being immature
in their brains forming later jives with
the experience of just about every
parent and family I know where if you if
you have girls of the same age
interacting with your boys you're like
wow these girls seem like a hundred
times more with it than my boys and you
and you and you don't
you know you don't like necessarily
impugn your boys by saying that I mean
like that like a lot of folks are having
very similar experiences but
unfortunately that's playing out
um in schools writ large yeah and I
think it's it's a a really interesting
example of how it took the women's
movement it took progress on behalf of
girls and women to to expose some of
these differences and so as you say
there are these big gaps so you know a
few data points that you know well but
uh in college for example the college
Gap is huge now the the the percentage
difference between the women getting
four-year college degrees and Men is now
15 percentage points in favor of women
and that compares to a 13 percentage
point gap in favor of men in 1972 when
Title IX was passed to help women and
girls among those with the highest GPA
finishing High School two-thirds of
girls and among those are the lowest GPA
two-thirds of boys in the average school
district in the US now girls are almost
a grade level ahead in English and uh
and have matched the boys in math so
this there is sometimes this idea well
girls are better at some things boys are
better at other things well basically
now that's not true basically just girls
that matter everything
um and that great catching up and
overtaking has exposed the ways in which
the education system actually doesn't
suit boys very well and particularly for
the reasons you've identified and again
like I have three boys raising them
through adulthood and it is just a fact
that they the parts of their brain do
develop a little bit later on average
than that and it is the bit of your
brain the prefrontal cortex that is the
bit that says finish your homework don't
go to don't go out partying oh and also
turn in your homework the next day oh
and also maybe study for that test
because that test will affect your GPA
right and your GPA matters for your
college admissions and getting into
college might matter for your future so
it's about future orientation and there
just is there's a difference between
boys and girls and it's it's one of
those things where you have all this
evidence from neuroscience and you know
the all the psychologists and then you
you share all that with teachers and
parents and principals and they go well
duh like this basically fat is not it's
not surprising to them but we ignore it
in our education policy like why why is
that fact is so obvious to everybody do
you ignore it in the way that we
structure and time education for boys
and girls yeah so you have a a number of
recommendations three big ones which I
all agree with frankly number one is the
most interesting and I think has gotten
the most publicity which is Redshirt the
boys let's just have boys start school a
year later uh the other two just so
people have a sense of it
um it is to uh invest in vocational
education
uh and the the third was drug my memory
uh more male teachers
yes and this is just an education those
are the three big education ones that's
right yeah yeah so what is the response
been to Red shirting uh boys for a year
which I think is a great idea uh you
know I've advocated for a gap year
um as an example heading to college
because the maturation serves people
really well yeah that is that is an
alternative for people who proposed
including in the UK there's been this
debate about should you know should you
have this Gap year especially for boys
but my view is that we should just start
earlier right if we if we know that that
Gap is coming if we know that
developmental Gap is coming and it's
particularly wide in adolescence why
don't we just anticipate it right so
your your idea is better than doing the
Gap year later because a lot of the data
shows that the boys are struggling
earlier on and you want to actually have
a foundation enjoy learning not have
Behavior yeah Etc yeah I mean my view is
that in there rather than letting them
fall behind and then try and catch up
later why don't we try and help them
keep up right it's easier to keep up
than to catch up and so I think we start
them in in school a year later it means
that just developmentally they'll be
closer to equal right so one of these
weird things like the chronological age
that we choose to start kids in school
is very arbitrary uh it's a proxy for
development but it turns out that it
differs on average between girls and
boys and so let's actually just bake it
in from the beginning I think it's one
of this it's one of those suggestions
that sounds incredibly radical to a lot
of people except every parent and
educator and principal I've spoken right
so they all go yeah of course you should
do better to them it's blindingly
obvious
um but of course it would need to be
piloted and evaluated but that's the one
I think that's interesting that's got
some more pushback interestingly other
the others in theory the idea that we
should spend more on vocational learning
and the fact that we should at least try
and arrest the decline in a number of
male teachers in our classroom most
people are like they're on board with
over those ideas the red shirting one is
a little bit more controversial I would
say and there are good arguments against
against the policy as well as in favor
of it which I try to take seriously in
the book
um but overall what I'm being pleased by
is the when people are disagreeing what
they're saying is I don't think that's
the best way to help boys
okay right let's have a discussion then
about the best way to help boys but at
least we're having the conversation now
about boys which means we've accepted
the fact that they might need more help
foreign
people on the internet one half of
Gillian keeves and someone I have a
little bit of shared history with Shane
Gillis welcome Shane I'm happy we
finally got to actually sit down yeah me
too so you and I spoke back in 2019 uh
and so you know like if people are like
Shane Gillis that sounds Vaguely
Familiar and you're in an Andrew Yang
fan so to re-cast this September 2019
some very exciting announcements are
made about the new cast of Saturday
Night Live it includes bow and yang
Chloe Feynman and Shane Gillis and so
you are exultant for approximately how
many hours I probably had 24 hours
because I knew I was going to get a I
got the call that I was going to be on
the show a day before
and then when yeah once it got announced
I probably had about
six hours it didn't take them long okay
so then six hours later news came out
that you had made some uh offensive
comments on a podcast maybe like you
know X months earlier about me
personally I was on there and then other
groups I think Asians were certainly on
there uh maybe maybe some others I think
all of them for sure yeah I mean every
group every group so it got me on Asians
though like I just heard about the Asian
thing yeah which is a it's a funny thing
to get me particularly for one thing
because then it seems like that's
like something I'm actually like you
know what I mean now it looks like I
just am a guy going around like [ __ ]
I hate Asians it's like no dude well you
know what I mean I'm you know it does
make sense because that's the way I
remember the news coverage and that's
obviously how it came to my attention so
uh I see this and then I'm like okay who
the heck is this guy and my wife's like
who the heck is this guy so we sit down
and watch some of your comedy and pretty
quickly conclude that you're not some
you know malignant uh rancid like
ranting type yeah that you seemed like a
comedian uh and at that time I made a
statement saying look like I don't like
some of this humor but no one should
lose their job over
making comments on a podcast you know I
didn't say this at the time I was like
podcast said frankly no one [ __ ]
heard me like no no it's like like that
no one listens no no one listened and so
someone took the time to be like okay
hear these things you're an
up-and-coming comedian I thought that in
this case it was like look uh and at the
time even when I made the statement I
didn't think that they would listen
um but I said as someone who is
personally slurred I don't think that
this is something that someone should
lose a job over yeah and and then uh so
during this time what's happening to you
oh
um yeah just getting
canceled
and so what is it
what do you say being crushed so the
news stories start coming out and then
what happens
uh you just start getting like
every tweet ever like I mean I was
number one on Twitter for like three
days just getting because there was a
debate that was the hard part was like
there was I understood both sides of the
argument like I I think everyone did
like he should be fired or he was just
joking so you go from the highest of
highs probably calling your parents
being like hey guess what like you know
yeah that was the first thing I was ever
able to like tell my parents in comedy
that they understood you know normally
be like Oh I'm featuring this weekend
for so and so they'd be like who cares
this was the first one I was like I'm
gonna be on Saturday Night Live they
were like wow wow we're proud of you
yeah you know and it must have been a
number of years to lead up to that point
and there were probably times when your
parents were not exactly pumped
social media is attacking you like are
you getting updates from your agent in a
particular way uh does someone yeah
just on the phone for like four days
straight I taught English in Spain for a
little and so I still had these Spanish
teachers that I was friends with and
then I didn't talk to them for like
three years then I got SNL when I was on
the news in Madrid they were like racist
like they all started hitting me on
Whatsapp like
Shane what the what happened like you're
racist I was like lo siento
Amigos I went to go do stand-up that
night and I was like oh this is going to
be the coolest night ever all the
comedians are gonna be like hey there he
is you know so I'm on the train from
Queens going into the City and my agent
calls and is like did you say
Bachelor and I was like no like I was
like I wouldn't say that I genuinely I
was like no I don't even why would I say
that and then she was like here's a
video of you saying it I was like holy
[ __ ] it was surreal it was totally
surreal I'm not like by the way I'm not
I wanted to be clear I'm not a victim
like I'm not like sitting here like oh I
can't believe what they did to me it's
like
no there's a video of me using a slur
it's like there's gonna be some backlash
yeah oh so and it's one of the things I
I've appreciated about your
um time sense and a lot of people might
not know this but you haven't frankly
responded to the way a lot of people do
if they are the recipient of like a lot
of energy which is to go to whatever the
opposite of that energy is yeah I tried
to make sure that because that's how
that's how it really like getting
canceled or however you want consequence
whatever uh that's how I think it really
gets you is if you let it
become who you are so around this time
um I my team puts me in touch with you
and I have a call with you during our
phone conversation I was like okay like
I felt good about the statement I made
saying like look I don't think this guy
should should lose his job yeah I I
really really appreciated that for real
like that was like I was like damn this
guy's awesome so SNL it may be one of
the highest watermarks in comedy and
they thought you were funny enough to be
there yeah and so there that has to feel
good yeah that was cool that was cool to
go straight to cast that was cool oh
yeah it was cool yeah a great six hours
apparently it was a good six hours okay
so I was on I was on a panel a number of
days ago with Chris Christie who now
people are down on for various reasons
but sitting with him he was both
talented and funny yeah and he made a
case to the folks that were there it was
like Hey you put me on a debate stage
with Donald Trump like I can really do
some damage
um and listening to Christy talk about
this I was like he actually could
because he's been around him alone is
kind of comfortable and he's got that
kind of manner like I I think that
there's some real
Merit to having someone with comedic
experience and abilities
particularly if you're running against
someone like Trump trump actually has a
lot of those he's very funny
he's undeniably funny yeah I honestly I
think he's undeniably fun oh I mean he's
no he's entertaining for sure he's got
he's also an incredibly experienced
performer the proportion of politics
that is performative is now Sky High
yeah and so if you have these performers
you have these political performers and
a lot of people are tuning out that sort
of performance now like there was a
theory I had that we're in like a post
inspiration age where if you come out
and you're like inspirational
um like Obama like now that stuff like
you know doesn't work as well because
they used it up they did it so often
with everything everybody was trying to
be inspirational like it'd be like is it
is that it's like you know it'd be like
oh great a significant proportion of
them almost seemed like they're
imitating Obama too because that's the
template for sure and it doesn't seem to
work no and now there's going to be a
probably a wave of dudes imitating Trump
which that's tough to pull off he's one
of the only guys I think that can do
that which is get away with everything
oh I I a thousand percent agree with you
that Trump is going to spawn a whole
Legion yeah uh of which will be fun to
watch for imitators it'll be funny
to see guys try to be mean on the debate
stage that'll be fun well there was a
moment in 2016 when Marco Rubio tried to
imitate Trump and it was just it's also
flat yes it doesn't work
um you have to to be able to pull it off
in a certain way Jeb tried Jeb started
chirping back
and he got crossed he was like you're
high energy tonight Jim I like that it
was like
oh so [ __ ] good at talking [ __ ] and
everybody else had to play by the
political rules everybody else had to
don't be rude
be a politician be good and he's up
there just bullying people overrunning
them
I am pumped to welcome to Ford world
class poker Champion
best-selling author of the book in my
hand die with zero getting all you can
from your money and your life hedge fund
manager epic investor Bill Perkins
welcome to forward bill
thank you thanks for having me I'm glad
to be here yeah so you you tell the
story too which I I laughed out loud so
your boss tells you look uh you're doing
it wrong you should not be trying to
scrimp and save you know a thousand
bucks if you're here to make a fortune
and you're like oh yeah you're right so
you start spending too much uh and then
you fall asleep at your station and get
fired
[Laughter]
oh yeah this is another job but yeah
and but then you end up switching to uh
another job as a broker which is not
what you precisely want to do but that
ends up leading you to a role in Houston
Texas where you are now uh right and
there are a lot of people that might
have hesitated about moving to Houston
from New York especially if they wanted
to work in you know training because
like oh you know like all the action is
in New York but then you looked at it
and said oh like like sure I'll make
this move and uh there was like there
were a couple of principles in there uh
where in your book you talk about trying
to be bold when you're young uh and
think about what you have to lose
because a lot of people
over emphasize what they might be giving
up and underestimate what they might be
gaining by writing a decision right they
don't look at the opportunity cost right
like of of the cost of inaction and and
I was one of those people that was like
I'm never moving south on the
Mason-Dixon Line like what the hell
never go to Texas like Texas was like
rednecks and racists and cowboys and you
know I had the stereotypical image
largely informed from uh past and TV
right and you know I didn't really know
what Texas was like I hadn't been there
but you know I was I was like I had the
Texas of the 60s in my head you know and
so not not the Texas that it was when I
moved down there but fortunately for me
I was so passionate about uh becoming a
Trader and and wanting to do it and and
this kind of like arrogant belief that I
could do it that I would have moved to
Siberia I would have went anywhere I was
like what's the worst that can happen
you know I mean if they get me they get
me you know this and I and I made the
move and and luckily I had that attitude
about it uh to do it and you know as I
look at other people in different
careers I see people like oh there's
this job and you can move here and
they're like oh I don't know I don't
know anybody there I'd have to move here
or Etc and a lot of jobs or
opportunities go unfilled not
necessarily that people can't do it but
they're not willing to take the
emotional risk of moving right uh
meeting new friends that that that
friction right and so they they stay in
a situation that may be less than ideal
or even painful like I say one of my
sayings is people will avoid paying to
live in misery and I'm not saying
everybody's a misery that doesn't move
but you know some gradient of that
happens
with that fear yeah you talk about a
sales clerk who doesn't like her job and
you're like hey you need to leave
because the fact is you could get
another job you don't like you know
immediately yeah
exactly yeah and and that that rang true
to me uh a lot of and so the the book
has different guidance for people at
different life stages and for young
people uh it's around trying to
hone in on what you can gain from taking
action as opposed to what you might lose
and taking more risks when you have less
to lose like be bolder when you you have
fewer responsibilities
yeah the downside is is right like you
know at the end of the day when I was
like scrimping and saving and and the
risk of the floor is like I could have
got a job literally at a fast food
restaurant and got paid more right like
they purposely pay you low because of
the opportunity set that's there and
you're gonna go make right and so going
going you know and it's like could I
could have been a waiter I could have
done any things like I was always going
to survive
uh you know survival wasn't an issue it
was just my ego of what what was I
willing to do it when I fell down right
and so I should have been taking you
know Max Max risk in certain areas of my
life I did in certain areas I didn't you
know in terms of like emotional risk or
taking a travel or et cetera like I
could have got another job as a screen
clerk who climbed the ranks easily like
I was one of the best screen clerks
there ever were I'm gonna say that I'm
just gonna say that you know like so
like uh you know I missed out right I
missed out on on that something that
can't replace that period of my life has
died that season is gone and it is now
either you know I I don't either don't
have the aptitude or the attitude to go
do it that way now
so you moved to Houston Texas and become
an energy Trader and end up being very
successful one of the big principles of
the book is around trying to figure out
what your uh life experience money
trade-offs are when you're on autopilot
and you're just like hey I got good at
this thing this thing produces money I'm
going to keep money when money becomes
the goal and not the tool to fulfill
your life you just keep going on
autopilot right the purpose it's like I
always tell people like Hammers and saws
you can like make the best Hammers and
saws but that's not the goal the goal is
to build a house but some people get
stuck just accumulating Amazon
so the money is a tool to to enhance
your life not the other way around and
so I think I think um even even at all
income levels right
you know people need to get to the
concept of enough and to know enough you
have to get off on a pilot like what do
I what experiences do I want in my life
what things are going to fulfill me
right uh and then once you have that you
know exactly how much money you need
yeah you talk too about time with your
kids and you're you're a parent you've
got two girls right
right I've got two boys
um and that itself also is like a scarce
resource or a trade-off where if you
don't spend time with your kids during a
certain
year like you don't get that year back
uh and and so there's also like an
investment in that regard it's like and
you might think to yourself oh I need to
make this money so that I can provide
for my family but
spending time with your kids actually is
an investment in them as well that in
some ways might be as or more important
and one of the things I love about you
and your approach to things like You're
so hyper rational about everything
where and we'll talk a little bit about
this where you don't stop with this book
you actually have produced a couple of
apps to help people optimize their time
money trade-offs but it instinctively
made sense to me that if you're spending
all your time and you make this point in
the book if you spend all your time
making money for the family and none of
your time actually with your family like
time spent with the family would have a
much higher return
[Laughter]
for the child uh that then like another
couple bucks in a lot of situations
right if you look at money as a tool to
fulfill you right like it's basically a
tool fulfillment the first the first
level is survival right and then after
that we're operating on a want basis not
a need basis so once the needs debate uh
met we're operating on a want basis
and one of the things that your kids
want uh whether they consciously or or
or unconsciously is time with you
memories with you moments with you and
so piling an extra million dollars on it
but taking away that time from you is
basically giving them something useless
right what they want is time with you
right and I'm not saying I have the
answer to the the optimal balance right
like it's it's it's it's almost an
intractable problem but like these are
the things we need to think about uh so
that we get more close to the optimal
solution of balancing time with kids or
family members or loved ones or or what
have you yeah there was a lot of wisdom
in your book too about different life
stages where after you made some money
being a good grandson you give your
grandma ten thousand dollars uh and then
she doesn't do anything with it uh and
turns around and it gives you like a
sweater yeah yeah exactly sweater my mom
corrected me she also gave my daughter
like a chain like a small chain but like
it really hit home that uh you know the
utility of money changes as you age it
really becomes you know useless because
the number of activities that either you
enjoy doing or can do declines right
like and and this is just a natural
thing and I used to think oh not me I'm
going to be swinging from the
chandeliers in the club when I'm 70 you
know what I mean and I look at my
grandparents I'm like oh who am I
kidding like these are my ancestors this
is the way my even my dad you know who
was kind of kind of out there and you
know they just
they just shift into gears and so uh you
know the the the wealth planners or life
planners say you know there's a go go
years of the slow go years and the no-go
years and that's pretty much true for
universally true for everyone and so
those uh you know I call them Chuck E
cheese tokens that those dollars you
have the the the the Chuck E cheese
tokens for partying or ski trips or
doing this whatever they expire right as
you age and they become useless and what
I mean is that
a certain amount of your money just
becomes useless to you it's not it's not
it's not it doesn't fulfill you the same
way it could have or at least the
activities that fulfill you start to
disappear
foreign